Speaker 1: OK, I do want to get to something
a little more substantive. We continue to
see this debate over statues and monuments and
statues are getting pulled down when they are
sometimes Confederate statues or whatever the
case may be. And we have another example of that
in Virginia. In Richmond, Virginia, a Robert
E. Lee statue has been removed. Robert E. Lee,
a big Confederate general, essentially a
traitor. It was Robert E. Lee was a guy
fighting against the Union, a.k.a. the United
States at the time for the right to continue
owning slaves. He was a pro slavery traitor to
the United States is the way that I would put it.
Robert E. Lee statue was taken down in
Richmond, Virginia, and Donald Trump put
out a statement saying that the statue was
magnificent and Robert E. Lee was a genius.
What I mean, it it's beyond words, it's beyond
words. Let's take a look at the statement this
put out through the Save America PAC of President
Donald Trump. Trump says just watched as a massive
crane took down the magnificent and very
famous statue of Robert E. Lee on his horse
in Richmond, Virginia. It has long been
recognized. It's waxing poetic about a
Confederate statue. It has long been recognized
as a beautiful piece of bronze sculpture. To
add insult to injury, those who support this
taking now plan to cut it into three pieces and
throw this work of art into storage prior to its
complete desecration. Robert E. Lee is considered
by many generals to be the greatest strategist
of them all now greatest strategist. This is like
saying Nazi. The German army's Nazi strategist,
Hermann Goring was really a good strategist.
That doesn't mean we have a statue for the guy.
OK, Robert E. Lee is considered by many generals
to be the greatest strategist of the Mall.
President Lincoln wanted him to command the north,
in which case the war would have been over in one
day. Robert E. Lee instead chose the other side
because of his great love of Virginia and
except for Gettysburg, would have won the war.
He should be remembered as perhaps the greatest
unifying force after the war was over. Ardent in
his resolve to bring the North and South together
through many means of reconciliation and imploring
his soldiers to do their duty and becoming good
citizens of this country. Our culture is being
destroyed in our history and heritage, both
good and bad, are being extinguished by the
radical left, and we can't let that happen. If
only we had Robert E. Lee to command our troops
in Afghanistan, that disaster would have ended
in a complete and total victory many years ago.
What an embarrassment we are suffering because we
don't have the genius of a Robert E. Lee. This is
what the former president of the United States
has been relegated to, praising pro slavery
Confederate generals as geniuses and bemoaning
the removal of a statue. Now, I've said before,
I actually don't pay too much attention to
this statue stuff in that I. I don't find it
particularly substantive. Now, if you come to me
and you say, David, sir, do you would you remove
the statue? Yeah, of course I would remove it.
Or would you rename the middle school away from
being named after a Confederate general? Yeah,
absolutely. Absolutely. But for me, it's not a
big substantive focus is the point that I'm trying
to make. But the bemoaning it as the greatest loss
also strikes me as completely unhinged,
deranged and wacky. So there is Trump saying
this man was a genius. This proslavery general
who fought for who fought for the Confederacy
is a genius. And the statue is magnificent and
it should remain. That's just horrifying stuff.